[Music]
welcome back to google cloud 9 l 117 in
San Francisco I'm Timothy Jordan a
developer advocate and host of the dev
shell and I'm drea sponsor a program
manager on Google for education and when
the host for the g sweet show so this is
the last day of google cloud next and
what a week it's been that's right dria
today is dedicated to open source and
cloud native architectures with deep
dives on Cooper Nettie's and tensorflow
will hear from startups and the venture
capital community about how they're
leveraging the cloud just as action
packed adjuster day and speaking of
yesterday we put together some of our
favorite moments for you to enjoy and
here they are our network it's probably
the largest global network today between
25 and 40 percent of global Internet
user traffic we put a security tips on
all our new machines to serve as the
basis of trust for that machine's
identity if actually so small that I'm
actually wearing one on my earring here
a g3 with obsessed with the idea that
computers should constantly raise the
bar on one team can get dollars at the
Monday so that our users your employees
have more and more time to focus on
truly creative work the cloud enabled
innovative business models new ways of
you creating and changing your business
that you wouldn't have been able to do
before Jam board is the whiteboard in
the cloud in the meeting room and beyond
your meeting room you just picked up the
stylus and you start thinking
communicating and working with your team
why do they come in ggp they want the
world's best security they want to be on
a flywheel of continued innovation
all available through an API the core
promise the developers still remain the
same bring your code and Google will
handle everything else so that was day
two dria you also had a chance to talk
with someone about stackdriver right you
know I sure did I talked with a mirror a
product manager on stackdriver about
monitoring logging and diagnostic for
the clouds let's check it out hi
everyone I'm here with a mirror who's
leading a session about alerting best
practices called the thin line between
informing and over informing that
everyone will have an access to in the
next couple of days so America for we
dive into your session tell us more
about what you do at Google ok hydrea
I'm also excited to be here so auto
product manager on Google cloud platform
and I focus on our stock stackdriver
services sweet stackdriver is all about
monitoring logging and diagnostics for
our users that are running their
applications on cloud services and I'm
based here in Mountain View so when it
comes to as we mentioned the topic of
the session a learning best practices
but also morning more about staff driver
why is this important we're thinking
about the cloud so over the years we
work with a lot of our users you know
making sure they have everything set up
correctly and their correctly monitoring
their applications and we realized that
alerting is the hardest part to get
right and so we wanted to use this
opportunity to share the things we've
learned both with that driver and
monitoring inside Google to help our
users and users of other you know cloud
platform providers get alerting right
for example we come across cases where
users alert too often or they don't
alert on the right things and so we want
to share our insights right and then how
does stackdriver fit into all of that so
sad driver is our service that enables
users to alert on things that they run
in the cloud but the third session is
also applicable to users of other either
competing services or free free services
as open source so it's really applicable
to anyone that some that's running
production services in the cloud and
they want to make sure that their users
are presented with sort of their best
foot forward right and so in addition to
leading some of the sessions on that I
guess for you what are you most excited
about when it comes to the future of the
cloud and it comes to the specific
products that you're working on ok so
with the last act driver and generally
cloud I'm really excited to see that the
focus is shifting from maintenance and
that kind of over had to really innovate
in innovation so users today have better
tools that are it's easier to setup and
require very low overhead and so they
can focus their efforts and sit on
instead of on maintaining on innovating
and so that leads to better applications
and better services and you know more
exciting things that we see out there
right exactly well Amir thanks for
joining us today and give us a little
sneak peek into your sessions that
you're going to be doing at cloud next
and we'll definitely have a chance to
check it out on youtube when our
recorded sessions Thank You 'try how
thank you and of course Timothy I get to
spend some more time in the cloud
showcase and just like yesterday we
thought wouldn't it be cool if we
brought you along as well let's check it
out so here we are at the jam board and
I'm standing with ashwariya Aishwarya
could you tell the live stream viewers
what you do at Google yeah I'm a product
manager on the jam board team so for
those few people out there that don't
yet know what a jam board is what is it
chambord is a fun digital collaborative
whiteboard everyone loves how it looks
it looks great in the room the first
thing people walk to and it's fun just
to like write on it the other thing it
is is it's a great collaboration device
for people who are working for example
in remote offices so you could be in New
York and I could be in London and let's
say you're on a jam board I could pull
up my tablet and we could be jamming on
the same file and we can collaborate
together sketch just anything that you
would do on like a normal white board
you could do on this Jan board but
instead of taking a picture at the end
of the session and emailing it to me we
could be doing
real time and you can just send it to me
add people and then you can add me
that's all that's awesome I mean I know
we spent a lot of time on VC and there's
there's white boards behind us you pass
catching sort of have to turn the camera
you can take a picture I'll recipe and
it just adds so much overhead to the
collaborative process when you're in
different offices exactly now you
mentioned you like some of the sketching
and handwriting we can do boo airs and
the other kind of like cool things that
we can I pop in and do some
brainstorming on yeah so for example
let's say we want to talk about dogs
during a meeting so once these images
show up you can just hold them out like
and then chain them up and then if you
want to delete slide them down so that's
something really cool and then another
thing that I love is a web search so
anything that you would search on like
google com you can just search in here
let's say I want to go to New York City
and I just want to pull up a map of
Manhattan this will take a while but you
can just like crop out the image and
pull it into your gym and start writing
on it mark places on it star places we
send the files to your friends you can
all like mark different places at the
same time pulling images like right
don't a place general images donuts from
that place another thing that's pretty
awesome is the handwriting recognition
so not everyone has amazing handwriting
like me so for people like those
there you go that was really cool and
then you can also scale these yes well
thank you for the quick tour of the GM
board I exactly what start damning this
is the meet the experts area where
developers get to ask experts from
google their questions and work on
solutions together I'm going to join
drea over here who found some of the
firebase crew we're going to talk about
something that just launched hey y'all
how you doing all right so this is doug
and he's going to tell us about
something but just launched yeah so
today we just announced Google Cloud
functions for firebase which is a tool
that lets developers right back in code
that response to events in their
firebase project now I'm really excited
about this but some people might not
know exactly what that's for so why
don't you tell us what developer
problems does this salt yeah so what we
found is that developers really don't
want to create their own servers
maintain them upgrade them and
constantly deploy to them so what they'd
rather do is just right there code
deploy it to Google service and let
Google handle all of the you know
administrivia you know the ops and all
that so it's a really great tool that
developers are using to build their the
backend for their mobile app so tell us
where do we go to learn more and how to
developers get started with them yeah so
you can go to firebase google com you
can find the functions feature there and
there's instructions to get started you
can get get going with that right away
awesome hold up thanks a lot y'all will
catch you soon all right so here we are
in the g street area and i found west
and tell us a little bit about what's
going on I West everybody how are you
doing we're doing great now one of the
things that I think is really cool about
what G suite offers is just a little
something for people to build things to
solve problems in their enterprise no
matter what their technical skill level
can tell us a little bit about that
sweet right exactly so we have like
developer tools that for people who are
full-time developers but we also have
stuff where you know if you're trying to
get something done trying to build like
a little app to like put together report
you don't have to be a hardcore
call for engineers so we have a cool new
product called app maker which is a low
code development environment where you
can go from idea to app in days not
months and you don't really need an
engineering resource all you need to do
is be able to drag and drop things and
you can build a simple UI add the
connectors in boom all of a sudden you
are done and gone the next step up if
you really want to do a little bit more
work is that app maker runs on top of
apps script which is google javascript
in the cloud environment that gives you
access and your apps access to data in
Google Apps a deeply in you know you can
access other Google services but you can
also make external calls to like you
know and outside relational database and
then for the hardcore software
developers then we have the rest api's
where you can actually integrate Google
Drive gmail calendar sheets and slides
into your applications a lot of stuff so
we also there's also been a lot of G
sweet announcements and product updates
talk to us about some of your favorites
are highlight from those ok great this
morning we announced that team drives is
generally available which is really
exciting because now you know if
employees move or change jobs you don't
have to worry about all who do we resize
the corner kick you right it's crazy so
everything is owned by the organization
and team drives is accessible from the
drive API as well so your apps can
integrate with team drive the other
announced that that was exciting this
morning was a gmail add-on where you can
integrate your mini app and have it
built into gmail so that they can access
your app without having to leave gmail
you know it's kind of like that breaking
the cycle of oh I'm working in gmail all
I gotta pop out go to another app and
right I got to get back into gmail leg
exactly and your contact is kind of
crazy so if you can actually build in a
little bit of your app within gmail
values for a better seamless user
experience awesome alright we'll go that
last question if people want to get
started on any of this where should they
go sure best place to go is developers
google com you can find apps script
there you can find app maker their Gmail
add-ons google drive and team run
thank you so much that all right there
hey guys but to everyone we're here at
the cloud spanner booth with Selena so
before we talk about what we're doing
here playing it tells more about what
you do at Google I do product marketing
for GCT databases now we're at the
spanner boot and spanner is something
that I'm particularly excited yeah you
are Liana I've talked a lot about it I
you know but I've always been frustrated
by having to choose between horizontal
scaling and strong transactional
consistently but with spanner I don't
have to choose yeah I knew you really
hit the nail on the head there you don't
have to choose and that having a
relational database that also scales
horizontally and keeps the strong
transactional scale is huge and that's
we're really excited about and not to
mention it's also in the clouds so it's
fully managed yeah that makes it a lot
more easy to implement right and where
can we go to learn more about it cloud
google.com / banner that was easy thank
you so much thankful eat it well dria
it's almost time for the end of our
pre-show oh it already yeah of course
that means it's almost time to the final
keynote that's true and today's keynote
has an awesome lineup dedicated to open
source and cloud native architectures
will do deep dives into Cooper nannies
and tensorflow and then we'll hear from
Vint Cerf by vice president and chief
internet evangelist at Google on the
history and value of free open-source
software for infrastructure next Google
senior fellow Jeff Dean will do a deep
dive into tensorflow and then Sam romsey
VP of Product Management for compute and
developer services at Google Cloud we'll
talk about building an open cloud will
hear from startups and the venture
capital community on how they're
leveraging the cloud to build the next
wave of innovative products and services
and finally Alison wagon filled VP of
Marketing at Google cloud will close out
the keynote well let's get to it think
we should do that that's it for us but
don't forget to connect with us online
our twitter handles or on your screen
enjoy the show and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]